by now you've heard of Bitcoin the
world's first and biggest cryptocurrency
and the blockchain its underlying
technology and how together they have
the potential to change everything from
record-keeping to the global financial
system the blockchain is a radically
transparent platform that allows people
to trade with each other in a way that
bypasses the need for traditional
contracts and intermediaries bitcoin is
free market money that runs on the
internet and isn't controlled by a
political entity or central bank that
sounds exciting as hell but if you're
like me you struggle to understand
exactly how a fully decentralized money
and public ledger system are going to be
implemented and brought to bear on
everyday life so meet Caitlyn long one
of ink magazines ten business leaders
changing the world through tech you need
a true fair free capital market in order
to have a vibrant economy and we don't
have that today and that's what we gain
by blockchain she's also a former
managing director of Morgan Stanley and
the current president of Symbian which
is bringing blockchain technology to
Wall Street you became interested in the
Austrian School of Economics in 2008
during the financial crisis why did it
take the financial crisis to make you
interested in the Austrian school and
what are its essential insights into
kind of Bitcoin or blockchain technology
sure I was in the industry for 16 years
before the financial crisis happened and
the system worked pretty well and even
today it still does but that hiccup I
knew there was a bigger story than what
we were reading in the mainstream press
and it was ironically Tim Geithner's
interviews that he gave very close
together the first one in which he said
interest rates were too low and that's
why the mortgage market imploded and the
second one he said we should lower
interest rates even more so you had
somebody who clearly was talking out of
both sides of his mouth or didn't
understand from minute to minute what
was going on potentially both yeah I
don't know but that's what got me
curious and I started asking all of my
big thinker friends who who were more
thoughtful about the way the system
really worked and one of them said start
reading the Mises Daily Mail and you'll
figure out how the Fed works because
by that point I knew the Fed was at the
center of of the financial system and
there was something that just didn't
quite make sense so I went deep down the
rabbit hole so what what is it about the
feds role that you think was central to
the to the financial crisis and then how
does the Austrian school kind of respond
to that or you know clarify that for
sure and by the way I didn't just go
into Austrian school I looked at
everything because I just didn't accept
the mainstream explanation but but but
what I figured out was that we didn't
have a free market in money and the most
important price in the economy that
should absolutely never be tampered with
is the price of borrowing money in other
words the interest rates and
specifically it's the money market rate
of interest that should always be free
because that's what gives entrepreneurs
the red yellow green signals as to which
in which sector to invest in and over
what tenor to invest short term versus
long term and so the Fed by manipulating
interest rates and the money supply and
things like that and it screws with we
don't really know what money costs at
any given point
that's exactly right I do I am confident
in saying that interest rates would be a
lot higher today a lot then they would
be if if we lived than they are today if
we actually had a free market in money
no question because you'd have to
compensate savers for the risk so how do
you know so what about the Austrian
school appeals to you that there was an
aha moment for me when I read an essay
that had two graphs that described as a
simple supply demand for for money and
it showed that the disconnect the
Hayekian triangle was really what it was
in a simplistic form and it showed the
disconnect and made me realize oh my
gosh there's no question that supply and
demand for borrowing money are out of
whack and that rates should be higher
and bye-bye rates being lower where we
are subsidizing capital destruction and
it just was coming out of course with a
vengeance at that point but we're back
at it we're doing the same thing today
now the Austrians also tend to believe
you know they hate fiat currency and
they love the gold standard do you
believe in a gold standard because
you're a big Bitcoin
watch-chain person and it seems like the
gold bugs and the Bitcoin people don't
get along very well yes it's so true
it's fascinating because I'll be at
Austrian events and folks will come
running up to me how is this how did
this work again and I think it's because
the Bitcoin fits in them in the men's
Aryan definition of money better than it
fits in the Massassi and definition of
money I'm really in the way yeah no
that's yeah well like okay Karl with a
came anger yeah wrote a tremendous essay
in 2014 explaining how Bitcoin actually
does fit with Mises regression theory of
money and I think he's right that the
value the use value of Bitcoin isn't
just the coin itself it's that Bitcoin
is intertwined with a payment system and
so you've got the the unit of value a
small be Bitcoin along with the payment
system itself capital be Bitcoin and
they're intertwined and that's that
that's what the Austrians could use if
they if they so chose and it's just that
in the 19th century or 20 early 20th
century was gold that performed that
function right and then actually you
asked earlier what what what should be
money my answer is whatever the free
market says money is so III don't
necessarily advocate a return to the
gold standard though is you and I were
chatting before the interview there are
some central banks that are finally
stockpiling gold going exact opposite
direction as as other central banks in
the world and I find that fascinating
because they understand that backing a
fiat currency with real assets may
someday have value even though today
it's certainly not part of a zeitgeist
of central banks to do that well let's
let's talk about us and smart contracts
because that's what one of the ways you
describe it is that it's a smart
contract company yes are in all
contracts smart or at least for one of
the people maybe the person writing it
or the person signing it what do you
mean by smart contracts Marc contract is
a piece of code that autonomously runs
and it's essentially an automated
if-then statement what we interact with
it might feel like a smart contract
today something like online banking so
on the 30th of the month the computer
hits the atomic clock and says time to
pay your utility bill if there's money
in your account the bill gets paid
and you don't intervene at all now
that's not really a smart contract in
the blockchain context because when you
run that smart contract on a blockchain
what happens is that the payment goes
immediately to the payee right now
you've got that sexy front end of online
bill pay most users probably think
they're actually paying their bill at
the moment that they set that up or at
the when the computer it's the atomic
clock on the 30th of the month but in
reality the payment is going through a
spaghetti labyrinth behind the scenes
before it ends up at the payee and they
get it usually the next day and
sometimes even longer depending upon if
it's a foreign exchange payment so so
smart contract is essentially autonomous
computer programs it will feel like like
an online bill pay that automates
workflows that used to be manual but
it's going to be on steroids relative to
what we do today it'll be instantaneous
or yeah there is latency the speed of
light is the limitation on how fast it
can move so there is latency there not
always this means I think if I'm
remembering the theory of relativity my
twin who goes out to Alpha Centauri
he'll owe me a lot of money by the time
comes back and I'm an old man or he's an
old man so another way of talking about
this is that it's a distributed ledger
system so explain how I mean that seems
very close to the kind of smart contract
but it said the payment will be put
through the system and everybody will be
able to account for it so I'm you know
immediately yes essentially the golden
ledger that's the ah of Bitcoin that is
the payment system that Satoshi Nakamoto
invented that enables multiple parties
to see the same data at essentially the
same time and trust that it's valid when
we say essentially the same time we're
talking milliseconds of latency but
that's the ha that that multiple
untrusting parties who may not even know
each other and certainly don't
necessarily trust each other can share
one and only one copy of data and trust
that it's valid right you spend a lot of
time talking to risk managers and
insurance companies last year you gave a
speech to the National Association of
Insurance Commissioners which sounds
like the most boring conference of all
time
but where you said that black
technology could fix and I'm courting
you the lack of beneficial ownership
tracking of securities by the securities
industry now the content of the speech
is really fascinating but are you saying
that people in the stocks and bonds
business don't really have any idea of
who owns what that's exactly right
okay and so like that's really scary
right
it is and it should be most people don't
understand that yeah explain how how is
it because like every I think everybody
thinks they know who owns this or that
right what we owned in our brokerage
counts is an IOU from our Broker Dealer
just like what we own in our bank
account is an IOU from our bank we don't
really own our bank deposits just like
we don't really own the stocks the the
company that owns stocks is a company
called the DTC or technically a a
subsidiary called CD and Company it's
the biggest company that nobody has ever
heard of and frankly it owns 99.9
percent of the securities outstanding
and we think we have a capitalist system
pause on that and think about that how
difficult would it be for that entity to
be taken over by a hostile actor pause
on that but let's leave that aside and
presume that doesn't happen so they
literally it's a bookkeeping entity it's
something called a Clearing House that
was created back in the 70s by the SEC
to try to allow netting of securities
transactions in a in a market where
where too many trades were happening to
move the physical securities around fast
enough and so they allowed for it's
almost like the Wells Fargo stagecoaches
back in the 1800s with payments instead
of moving all the cash they just netted
the Rises the incomes and out goes the
debits and credits and just move the net
amount of cash as a means by which to
try to reduce risk in the system and at
the time it helped but what we're stuck
with now 40 years later is a market
structure that requires all trades to
clear through that central organization
which is part of the reason why it takes
a lot of time to clear trades how long
does it take to clear a typical trick
well we just went from T plus 3 to T
plus 2 in other words trade date plus 2
days but of course technology would
enable us essentially in real time to
clear those trails
I mean is it that people don't know who
on something at any given moment in time
or is it more kind of long-term than
that well you know that well we think we
bought this company but there are so
many intermediaries that we're not
really there that's right the accounting
systems can get out of whack and it's a
function of the latency and the number
of intermediaries through which the
transactions have to go and that's why
the system occasionally does lose track
of who really owns what I've encountered
it in my in my business when I worked on
the street working with a pension fund
where there was securities lending
happening that was unauthorized and they
wouldn't have discovered it but for the
fact we were working on a pension
transaction and then of course there
there are a number of instances where
naked short-selling has been revealed
but the most prominent one is the dole
food case that just came out of the
Delaware Chancery Court in February of
this year there were thirty-six point
seven million shares of dole food
outstanding and forty-nine point two
million applications with valid
brokerage statements for those thirty
six point seven million shares
outstanding so that Delta between thirty
six point seven and forty nine point two
was just phantom shares that were
created from the accounting system out
of thin air Wow so it's like starting
old time stock watering but this is
fully within the system it's fully in
the system it's it's fractional
reserving within securities as opposed
to fractional reserve banking which is
what the Austrian school was so you've
written that the the biggest
beneficiaries of blockchain technology
are long only investors insurance
companies pension funds mutual funds and
mom-and-pop investors they're the
biggest losers from today's lack of
beneficial ownership tracking in the
securities industry walk through how
blockchain technology fixes this it
restores the property right back to
those of us who think we actually own
what we think we own today but don't so
I mean in that case of dole foods
there's no way that there could be more
shares outstanding then we're actually
creative at the time because everything
gets accounted for immediately or you
know at the speed of light well and we
also can track it we own it so if
somebody is actually out there doing
something with our securities that
aren't authorized
then we would know we would be able to
see it this is one of the things I find
fascinating about blockchain a Bitcoin
and blockchain is that when it when
Bitcoin really emerged one of the
particularly on kind of dark websites
like Silk Road and whatnot the idea that
it was fully anonymous cash like
transactions but in fact it's not it's
the reverse of fully anonymous it is
fully tied to specific individuals
specific institutions specific moments
in time you know is that does that
trouble you at all a more accurate term
does it trouble me it depends on the use
case right because in it let's put it
this way for those who are looking for
better privacy in Bitcoin
there are next-generation projects that
have come out see cash Manero with much
greater levels of anonymity but in the
institutional world this is exactly the
sort of thing that we want we want to be
able to have clarity on who really owns
what and so the shenanigans that have
happened in the in the industry which
have skimmed value off people's
securities accounts on undetectably
those sorts of shenanigans need to stop
so within the institutional world that
transparency is a good thing because
guess what today we don't have it at all
it's it's not
nobody due until the very end there were
that many extra shares of dole food out
so this is and this is probably a
stretch but this is kind of like there's
going to be moments in the institutional
investing world where we open the safe
and it's like Geraldo Rivera going into
Al Capone's vault and what we thought
was stockpiled with good old-fashioned
booze there's like nothing there no or
there's you know a bunch of bears that
are about to eat you or something well
in the financial crisis as we were
talking about earlier one of the things
that clearly happened was the repo
market seized and it was a it was a bank
run it was not a bank run like we
expected where people were lined up
during the Depression you know around
the block waiting to take their bank
their money out of out of the bank and
we realized what fractional reserve
banking was
this is fractional reserve banking in
the Treasury bond market and it happened
electronically it was a bank run
electronically and there's an economist
at the IMF who tried to get a handle on
how many extra Treasury securities have
been created out of thin air it just
because of the way the accounting
systems of Wall Street work and he calls
it the velocity of collateral I won't go
into the details about why he calls it
that but in plain English what that
means is how many times has one
institution who owns a Treasury bond
lent it to someone else who also reports
that they own it
who's lent it to someone else who also
reports that they own it so you've got
three and that's the number he came up
with it used to be four now it's three
institutions who are all reporting that
they own the very same Treasury bond
when there's really only one this is how
the Fed is conducting monetary policy in
today's day and age I think that the
Austrian school is stuck in the old
traditional banking system where it's
all about money and m0 m1 m2 etc it's
now being done through Treasury bonds in
what's called rehypothecation and but
it's exactly the same pattern where
you're creating phantom assets that
don't exist and allowing the accounting
systems to get out of whack to do that
you know Wall Street is famously averse
to any sort of reform whether it's
imposed by the government or it you know
bubbles up through the markets I have
you know how is it reacting to
blockchain Bitcoin and associative
technology because I was working running
a business inside Morgan Stanley when I
discovered Bitcoin and then discovered
blockchain and believe it or not in the
beginning I was I had kept my head down
assuming like Jamie Dimon just recently
said that you know anyone involved in
Bitcoin would be fired that was my
presumption that that was going to
happen at that point in time but but
shockingly what happened is as this got
going the mainstream folks actually
reached out to people like me and the
different firms they found us through an
internal Bitcoin forum the chief
technology officer or Morgan Stanley
reached out and said hey you know
something about this come talk to me and
I was running a business so he trusted
me and I pulled me into a group of five
people who vetted everything that came
through Kenny can it be good if Morgan
Stanley is interested in it I mean I
mean is it just going to be co-opted
into maintaining the status quo no well
there are going to be attempts of that
there are backdoor attempts of that
right so there are a number
of projects that are supported by the
incumbents that have come out and
admitted their blockchain inspired but
in other words not not truly blockchain
but but if you adhere to the principle
of decentralization you can't have a
central actor co-opted and that's what's
so interesting about the approach of
symbian to the marketplace we're looking
for places within the market that are
naturally decentralized and oh by the
way guess what most markets are
naturally decentralized most markets are
naturally peer-to-peer when I'm paying
my utility bill why does there have to
be anybody into intermediating between
my utility and me right so over time I
think that decentralization will
actually tip so what are what are
markets then that you know say Wall
Street is particularly interested in
keeping decentralized or bringing
decentralization back because it seems
like Wall Street I mean the whole idea
of you know we're talking in New York it
was constant it's concentrated in a few
block area or was for four centuries
really or the trading districts and they
want centralization don't they well for
that it was concentrated for simply
because they had to move the paper stock
certificates around that's that's
settlement was when I delivered you the
actual paper stock certificate now
that's that's no longer the case but but
I think the dodd-frank actually pushed
and pushed us in a direction of
centralization ironically they missed an
incredible opportunity to push
decentralization and make the financial
sector healthier they did do something's
right in in increasing the capital
requirements so there are certain things
that have gotten better about the
financial system but that those central
organizations have become ensconce
and anytime you get somebody who's just
you know stick-in-the-mud ensconce we're
not going to change that that's an
incumbent that is difficult to disrupt
so there are lots of examples of of
central actors like that but I do
believe what will happen over time is
that decentralization will will show
that it's that much more efficient and
actually that lit that much less risky
and that the the market will eventually
move in that direction naturally you
know as a fellow I've been kind of a
philosophical sociological economic
observation there one of the
that is great about capitalism as it you
know as we generally talk about it is
the role of intermediaries because a lot
of times people don't understand the
value of what they own over here versus
what it would bring over here
intermediaries often are the people who
create value and this is you know the
rise of anti-semitism in Europe is you
know trace specifically to their being
involved in capital markets the overseas
Chinese are intermediaries they're
shopkeepers there are people who import
something to a place where it has more
value is you know in that sense does
blockchain kind of you know is it is it
a threat to capitalism as we understand
it and that essential function of the
intermediary no intermediaries won't
entirely go away so you're talking about
the example of shopkeepers they won't
they won't go away if they add value by
creating a marketplace you know a
grocery store where I know I can go get
my various and sundry items in one place
I don't have to go to lots of different
places that's that's a service that that
is valuable and the same thing will be
true of other intermediaries I don't
think that the investment banks for
example will completely go away they do
provide a real value in bringing buyers
and sellers together the stock exchanges
provide value and bringing buyers and
sellers together look at it in the
Bitcoin world there are now
cryptocurrency exchanges that bring
buyers and sellers together there's
value but what they're doing is taking a
fee this is the big difference in
today's day and age what they're doing
is running the assets through their
balance sheet and taking a cut of the
value and oh by the way if Lehman
Brothers goes bust before your trade
settles oh you're suddenly a creditor of
Lehman you thought you were buying a
share of stock and suddenly you've got
an IOU from a bankrupt institution
that's the piece that will get will and
should go away there's absolutely no
reason why financial intermediaries need
to have our assets moving through their
balance sheets on the way between buyer
and seller of a financial asset you've
written about how nobody knows how
leveraged the economy really is yeah
explain why that you know why that
presents risk and obviously blockchain
addresses it by kind of clarifying who
owns what at any given moment yeah so
this gets back to what I was talking
about in the Treasury bond market where
there are three Treasury bonds Oh
and reported is owned by every for every
one Treasury bond that actually exists
that makes each financial institution
look solvent but if you actually try to
pull out the double-counting guess what
the financial system is not a solvent as
it appears right and the Austrians would
say it's actually not solvent at all if
they're if everybody were to actually
grab their assets and and and take them
home so to speak so if the musical
chairs ever stopped you realize just how
insolvent the system is and it and just
like a traditional banking system works
that way so does the securities industry
it works that way and so the challenge
and actually there's a there's a
regulator Christian Carlo at the CFTC
who's been a big and early supporter of
blockchain he's the one who's out there
saying hey this is the tool that will
allow regulators to realize just how
leverage the financial system really is
so he's he's out there admitting this
not from ideological perspective but
from a practical perspective do you
think most regulators either kind of
would be regulators like senator
Elizabeth Warren or the actual people
who are going through financial Ledger's
and balance sheets do they understand
that and are they asking the right
questions and just giving the wrong
answers or are they not even asking the
right questions look I was in the
industry for 16 years in the weeds
before I figured it out so I think a lot
of people probably don't understand it
yeah but there are some who do you know
and you asked about Senator Warren that
that that wing of the of the Democratic
Party has diagnosed the problem
correctly just like the rod Paul wing of
the Republican Party has and it's really
that if there's a fundament of
fundamental fraud going on in our
financial system well to the extent that
multiple institutions are reporting that
they own the same asset at the same time
when there's really only one asset what
would you call that yeah I would like to
get in on that action for the collapse
is figured out right all these folks in
the dole food case how many people got a
free double-dip yeah
and stole value from mom-and-pop
sometimes I wonder whether when they see
those opportunities to sort of ARB the
system because the system doesn't keep
accurate track and then
they wouldn't get caught or presumed
they wouldn't get caught I wonder how
many of the folks who are doing that
actually stop and think about what that
means
and that is part of the settlement
process for kind of stock trades I mean
by you you were talking about you know T
plus 3 down to T plus 2 and that can
become you know basically where the
trade is instantaneous what what is the
issue with the stock trades taking so
long to settle what what kind of you
know what kind of funny business goes on
between them it's a market structure
issue so we talked about the creation of
the DTC don't need the DTC anymore from
a technology perspective because we
could settle trades instantly between
buyers and sellers or their agents like
a brokerage for a new brokerage firm
but what happens is right now literally
each institution that touches a stock
trade is Pro is sequentially processing
that trade so from your broker to the
custodian then the custodian has to
sequentially process at the DTC then
they sequentially process to the next
custodian to the broker so that's five
institutions who are touching a trade
literally having it run through their
balance sheet so again they're leveraged
institutions if anything fails in that
chain you're you're stuck with an IOU
and each one has to be processed in
sequence that's that's why under the
current market structure it's really
tough to speed this up because five
institutions have to process something
in sequence are there specific you know
illegalities that creep into the system
that you can talk about well the naked
short-selling
is technically illegal and explain that
for that's where you it's where you
where where you create securities are
lent out and it's not required to find
an actual security you just have to
verify that you could borrow it if you
wanted to so you can see how there's
room for interpretation on how many
securities there are outstanding and so
if you get a borrow you can borrow the
shares that creates a phantom share of
stock if it's not tied to an actual
share of stock that is illegal and our
friend Patrick Burnett oversaw comm ten
plus years ago really made a lot of
noise about that
because you can see how that
artificially suppresses the price of a
security again this gets back to how the
mechanisms in the in the capital markets
that skin value unfairly from
mom-and-pop because nobody is quite sure
who owns what at any given player charm
right and it you know back then it
really did suppress the value of over
stocks shares I believe Patrick had to
sell some assets at a fire sale value at
the time but now short selling is not a
bad thing right short selling is also a
way so why isn't it quiddity why is
naked short selling that because it
creates phantom shares right so if I'd
if I'm gonna short a share of stock as
long as I can tie my short to the actual
share stock that's that's that's that
there's tremendous value and pension
funds and insurance companies do
securities lending all the time and they
can collect extra income for that that's
absolutely legitimate and should be done
all day and about 20% of the trades in
securities markets are done on a short
basis so it's very much a part of the
liquidity in the market where it starts
to become a gray area is when you're
allowed to say well gosh maybe the I
don't have an actual share of stock I
can point to one over there but that one
might also have been pointed to by
somebody else and that's how you get
into the accounting being out of whack
and value being skimmed off last year
you made a prediction that involved
overstock.com Patrick burns company who
is you know one of the great kind of
evangelist for Bitcoin and blockchain
especially the prediction was that
overstock would issue public securities
that exist only in the blockchain in
December the last December they did just
that why is that a good thing or what
does that prove
well that paved a trail for the rest of
us to follow because they went through
the SEC approval process that is an SEC
registered security full disclosure I
own it personally an overstock in summer
of this year made an investment in my
company so full disclosure sure we're
philosophically aligned and working on
some things together but but that blazed
the trail for other issuers to follow
the the legal documentation that
overstock went through the heavy lifting
to get approval to do
that security doesn't trade very much
because it actually is in this in this
one place you have to have an account
with that one brokerage firm and so the
next generation versions of those
securities will be more liquid and
trading in more and more venues tell me
a bit about how different national banks
are starting to use Bitcoin or
blockchain technology to transform you
know their business
and and particularly the Russian
National Bank seems to be doing
something or Central Bank rather yeah
you know that is forward-looking in a
way you know we don't associate Russia
with anything other than looking back at
you know either the czars or the comet
itself is a country that's tended to be
on a different cycle than the rest of
the world because they haven't been as
connected to the OECD type countries and
of course they've in the last ten years
been frozen out because of sanctions
from the global financial system and so
it isn't a shock to me that Russia's the
first central bank that came out and
said that there will be a crypto ruble
and we don't know how their they will be
implementing it but it remains to be
seen I look at at the fact that Russia
has been buying gold in its central bank
all the Keynesian economists were saying
you should when that when the ruble had
a rough patch a couple of years ago the
Keynesian economists the IMF we're
telling him sell your gold protect the
value of the ruble and no they just let
it drop and they actually bought gold at
that point in time it's fascinating how
does you know how does a country like
Russia which is a low trust society to
begin with and then in the international
markets it's very sketchy I mean have
how will blockchain technology our
crypto rubles first will they be able to
make people actually confident that
there's something there or this is just
another scam but secondly how will that
transform the internal politics of
Russia which is a very secretive closed
society yeah well I spent I did the
trans-siberian Express last year so I
spent a lot of time I'm fascinated by
the history of the country is it better
better than I am track or about the same
oh well you know it's I've gotta tell
you Russia's vast it is it is I think
one and a half times the width of the
United States I mean it there instantly
when you're in Siberia there's a lot of
it a lot of that
let's put it this way Trane is the
method of transportation because the
highways are just it's too sparsely
populated for big for big highways and
and so it but what I saw was a
tremendous amount of Commerce and
especially a lot of oil tankers on the
train tracks but but back in on your
question about the crypto rule ruble it
all depends on how they implement it if
they implemented in a means by which you
can verify that the central bank became
a money warehouse and it's backed
one-for-one with something real and
russia remember is a very rich natural
resource economy so in addition to
having bought a lot of gold they in
China have been buying gold from the
other central banks in the world in the
last ten years in large size so if so
they could actually back their currency
with something real if they so choose so
the interesting to see how they
implement it is that kind of ironic
though that a crypto ruble needs to be
backed by gold coin sitting in a in a
vault somewhere well essentially it
becomes an electronic version of
whatever is on the central bank's
balance sheet as long as it's one for
one yeah yeah so that that and of course
you know a lot of the mainstream
economists would be probably scratching
their heads listening to us right now
saying why on earth would that matter
well it would matter because all of a
sudden if your capital goes to the place
where it's treated best and if the
central bank is not going to dilute you
by playing shenanigans like we were
talking about in the in the government
bond markets around the world namely the
Treasury market here but that happens in
all the government barn markets in the
OECD countries where there are more
government bonds than there actually
exists in the accounting systems so yeah
it depends on if Russia implements it in
a one-for-one manner when will the rest
of us realize that you know the
blockchain has one I think it's when you
see big financial institutions deploying
it as a means by which to create a
shared back-office and take a take out
all of the expense and the risk and the
latency in settling transactions and
essentially becoming service providers
that enable the peer-to-peer market and
we wouldn't necessarily in our
interactions with the blockchain know
that there is a blockchain because what
we'll see is just a nice web-based
front-end like we experienced we already
have
with with online banking but what the
difference is when you send money to
your friend on venmo they're going to
get the money right away as opposed to
waiting until the money shows up the
next day right if you if you deposit a
cheque in the bank today it's usually t
plus three before you get access to your
funds and that's because of those
intermediaries that we're talking about
on a blockchain basis you get an instant
I got to tell you the prank phone caller
and me is not looking forward to the
future in the same way that called
caller ID and did prank phone calls this
is you know let's let's have a moment of
silence for what we'll lose in a
perfectly transparent financial well at
a very fast financial system right for
sure but but but this is this is you
need a capital market in order to have a
vibrant economy you need a true fair
free capital market where most
especially interest rates are set by the
voluntary interaction of buyers and
sellers of borrowing and in lending
money and we don't have that today and
that's what we gain by blockchain well
that's a great note to end on thank you
so much thank you we've been talking
with Caitlin long she's a Bitcoin and
blockchain enthusiast and she's the
president of Symbian thanks again for
talking to us thanks Nick for reason I'm
Nick Gillespie
[Music]